it's exactly one year since we uploaded
a very first video onto YouTube and so
I've asked my colleague dr. Sam tang to
bake us a cake in the lab to celebrate
she's going to make the cake as far as
she can add two chemicals and using the
sort of apparatus that we normally use
in the lab I love making cakes I really
do enjoy making cakes I love the smell I
obviously love eating them to start with
making cake you need to cream together
the butter there are some things that I
just didn't have time to find the lab
based equivalents so I've had to cheat a
little here I'm sorry
you see cakes like everything else you
meet are made out of chemicals mostly
chemicals made up of carbon hydrogen
oxygen and nitrogen atoms with a few
other ones put in as well now normally
when I'm doing this at home I've got a
lovely kenwood chef and that would whiz
these together in a matter of seconds
the equivalent we've got here is an
overhead mechanical stirrer away we go
what we'll do is we'll lower that a bit
more so it's so we've introduced the air
but if we didn't do anything about this
all that's going to happen is that the
air is going to escape so what we need
to do now is introduce the other non
lab-based ingredient so what we're going
to do is crack that so what the eggs
going to do is going to provide a
scaffolding so each of the bubbles which
are surrounded by a layer of fats are
now going to be surrounded by a layer of
the egg if you've ever made the cake one
of the principal components is flour now
normally flour is mostly made up of a
starch so in this case we've pre weighed
out our starch now you may not know this
but different sorts of wheat produce
different proportions of protein and
starch and if you want to make bread
which you know it's quite hard you have
a flower that comes from a wheat that
has quite a lot of protein with cake
want to be really nice and soft and
yummy has much less protein one of the
key things about to cake is that it's
all nice and sort of blunt bubbly and
soft and the bubbles inside are caused
by gas and the gas is carbon dioxide
sodium hydrogen carbonate people will
know this as bicarbonate soda which you
can just get off a supermarket shelf so
bicarbonate soda and in order to get
that to produce carbon dioxide needs to
react and in order to react that's a
base it needs an acid and in this case
we've got tartaric acid the same is true
in bread because bread also has these
holes which are made very carbon dioxide
but the way you do it for bread and for
cake are a bit different in bread you
put in yeast which is a living organism
and the yeast digests some of the
ingredients of the dough that the
mixture for making bread and makes
carbon dioxide which causes the bread
and physically to rise in the case of a
cake people aren't patient enough they
want to eat the cake so there you mix a
salt of sodium that contains carbonate
ion or hydrocarbon eaten and the weak
acid like tartaric acid and these react
together in the cake and produce carbon
dioxide during the the baking and the
baking heating the cake is just a way of
promoting a whole series of chemical
reactions here's what actually is is one
of Martin's students supercritical water
reaction rigs this is the oven that
we're going to be using ok so what we're
going to do is actually turn it on so
all it is is just pean on the main so as
you can see there there is no way that
your home oven will heat up as quickly
as this
Oh No I've just realized pants um what
you do when I smelt it I'm really glad
you asked me to smell it because I've
forgotten an ingredient so this stuff
here is and it smells amazing
is vanillin so c8 h 803 8 carbons 8
hydrogens 3 oxygens and the way in which
they've been arranged gives you this
lovely aroma from it this is a hundred
gram bottle and I've got a tiny amount
from it but that will be enough so done
Oh twist it open pop it on top of the
heating block now that I've sealed it up
got our timer so what we're going to do
is time it for say 25 minutes well I
think that I and all the team are really
excited by the first birthday we never
imagined that there were so many people
who would be excited by chemistry and
would want to watch our videos we really
want to tell you about chemistry and why
we love it and also to answer your
questions because chemistry is
everywhere it's important in all our
lives and so I hope you will watch and
we look forward to celebrating our
second birthday next year okay let's see
how well this cake is cut so it's going
to be hot so you might want to stand
back a bit when this oven door opens
because I will woof so we'll see how
easy this comes out oh look at that
that's cake and you can see there it
feels like cake by golly it smells
really it smells good enough to eat um
but but we can't eat this because you
made it in the lab there are loads of
our chemicals around oh you'll find out
in a moment it's got a little bit of a
chemical additive that we've added just
to see if we can increase the sparkle in
the color of our cake
whoa I thought it was most unexpected
and like a real experiment you can never
predict the result